[Musik]
beruhigen
im übrigen
[Musik]
herr bundeskanzler sie werden der letzte
deutsche bundeskanzler gewesen sein der
die kriegszeit nach bewusst miterlebt
hat und dessen leben und denken und auch
politik durch die kriegszeit geprägt
worden ist die waren damals gerade 15
jahre alt geworden
wie hat der krieg was haben sie
persönlich erleben müssen
so wächst man ganz grundsätzlich ich
glaube dass man überhaupt nicht in
deutschland auf sich an das sowas wenig
kann man dort samt leben kommen vor
allem nicht an den brennpunkten
kriegsgeschehen der zanu pf krieg war
und dann der zusammenbruch spürbar war
ohne vom krieg geprägt zu sein ich habe
ein ganz einfaches mittel das ich auf
beobachtet haben
wenn gelegen in den letzten jahrzehnten
zur probealarm mit luft schutz für reden
war
kommen sie am verhalten der menschen
genau feststellen wer auf schaut und
sagt was ist dass wir eine eigene
erinnerung hat was luftschutz reden wir
bedeutend mich hat natürlich der krieg
geprägt ich hab ganz konkrete erinnerung
ich habe hier in 38 als die mobilmachung
war und aber nach der milch conference
wieder entwarnung kam aus mein vater
eingezogen wurden
und wieder kamen nach wenigen tagen und
dann habe ich die ganz konkrete
erinnerung die war sehr tief sitzende
wohl sie nicht verstanden haben
das war wenige tage zwei tage nachdem
erklären des zweiten weltkriegs nach dem
september wildes september als ich mit
meiner mutter und meinem vier jahre
älteren bruder mit vielen anderen leuten
an der rampe zur brücke mannheim
ludwigshafen stammt und die ersten
flüchtlinge des zweiten weltkriegs das
was wir natürlich nicht dass das so war
das waren viele arme bauern als der
südpfalz
der ganzen fahrt über gekommen war die
brücken castro war schon gesperrt wegen
artillerie-beschuss gefahr davon saucen
die speyerer brücke war von der armee
fixiert von den linken auf die rechte am
tag und die frau zogen und die frauen
auf meine mutter weinte des weinenden
und diese mehr armseligen bauern
fuhrwerke mit queen als leittier und so
das ist meiner erinnerung geblieben
und dann begann ja alsbald bei uns die
fliegerangriffe putics in ludwigshafen
ich kann mich genau erinnern was ich
natürlich weiß damals ich wusste zwar
betrag vor dem deutschen meister der
deutschen offensive war ein
französischer harmloser fliegerangriff
auf wirklich schaffen
und da ist eine kleine bombe vorgaben
gefallen nicht explodiert das war wie
dieser wollen
meine ersten erinnerungen dann habe ich
weit über 100 schwere flieger angriffe
wieder lebt man bruder ist im krieg
gefallen bei den luftangriffen dann
mussten sie als junge kann man ja sagen
eigentlich dann auch schon helfen dir
verletzt wurde so berger es war ja eine
praxis 644 die schule geschlossen
ein teil ist dann wir in die
nachbarschaft in nachbarstädte gegangen
in der mittelstufe anderen kindern mit
der kinderlandverschickung wie bekomme
ich ja auch noch dann ende 44 aber wir
haben dann schon mit großen busch wieder
löscht trotz entweder zu helfen
ausbrüche waren oder auch wenn ich von
unserem quadrat lager verschüttet waren
einfacher mitzuhelfen mit es
selbstverständlich war meiler kippen zu
bilden es gebrannt hat also wir waren
natürlich kinder über die kindheit war
nicht wer es war keine kindheit wenn sie
einmal dabei waren wie tote ausgegraben
dann bleibt das singen und wenn ich
nachts spät von der autobahn nach
ludwigshafen über dem rhein kommend
fahren
reich an dem haus vorbei das wieder
aufgebaut wurde wo ich zum ersten mal
dabei war die tote ausgegraben worden
ich denke nicht immer dran aber gelegt
die nicht häufig im auto oder musik und
böse so vor mich hin gelegen ich guck
ich hoch da ist das bild darf und sie
wurden dann verschickt und zum
flakhelfer eigentlich aus nein das war
jetzt wie man zur kinderland verschicken
damit die stunde x der übergang zum
flakhelfer begeister kriegsende bösen
vereidigt wurden wir am 20 april führers
geburtstag im stadion in berchtesgarden
paar tage vor kriegsende und das war
eine schreckliche zeit
dann sind wir mit einigen freunden
schulkameraden aufgebrochen zur längsten
wanderung eines lebenden weiter mit 15
jahren im juni 1945 schon fest es gab
möglichkeiten gelaufen
ich komme die scheibe überhaupt nicht
vorstellen wie das ist
das 15 ihre gärten soll zurzeit hinter
sich bringen gott sei dank ist das eine
vorstellung die gar nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar älterer bruder ist sehr
jung gefallen das hat sie hier geprägt
ja wir hatten eine gewisse drei kinder
meine schwester stellte die lieb
glücklicherweise noch mein bruder und
ich war natürlich der jüngste und mit
vier herren abstand schaut wir noch auf
den bruder auf kann einer autorität und
wir hatten sehr herzliches verhältnis
und ersten jahre mit 17 jahren soldat
geworden als mit knapp über 18 gefallen
darf ich eine sehr konkrete erinnerung
ist vor der invasion noch verwundet
worden dann habe ich im land besucht und
auf dem rückzug sei dann in westfalen
gefallen
das war schon aktiver 1 2
das war wieder etwas anderes wenn ihr
und ich habe vor allem eine große eine
sehr prägende erinnerung weil er sich
verabschiedet hat und hat mir das hat
mir gesagt noch auf dem bahnhof er kommt
nicht wieder habe ich nicht begriffen
aber jetzt viel später realisiert und
wenig gelegentlich verbands
soldatenfriedhof in deutschland begraben
in westfälischen dann will ich auch sein
grab kommen schon immer diesen satz wir
haben dann ihren ersten sohn nach ihm
benannt unser erster sohn heißt du her
firma meine frau gesucht und es war eine
wichtige entscheidung auch für meine
mutter war dieser name erst in der
dritten generation da als und bruder
meiner mutter ist zum ersten krieg
gefallen ihr vater hat im ersten
weltkrieg der schon bald eingezogen
zweiten weltkrieg wider und er war auch
in polen und hat ja wohl zu hause dann
auch erzählt dass das ziemlich
schrecklich sein was da passiert ist da
eigentlich schon etwas erzählt worden
über das was wir heute wissen wie bei
meinem vater mit diesen es wichtig
weniger fragen der war der inbegriff
einer seriösen pflichtbewussten
grundsoliden beamten großartiger mann
für die nato richtigkeit eine wichtige
sache war war ein einfacher bauernbub
aus dem fränkischen ersten weltkrieg als
soldat gewesen und über dekoration auf
die tier gebrochen und zweiten weltkrieg
war noch einmal als hauptmann bis dann
entlassen rocken und ich erinnere mich
in der tat an das frühjahr 1940
bei jenes
halde eher kalte winde der ungewöhnlich
hat war auch unter den verhältnissen und
wie es früher üblich war jetzt man ja
dann raus geschickt wurden erwachsene
besonders rät mit dem ergebnis und
besonders die ohren aufsteckte und hört
der weiß noch dass es war nicht
aufgegangen dass ich mein bruder fragte
was haben sie denn weil es waren freunde
von meinem vater war das war irgendwie
anders das war keine freude bestimmung
dass der urlaub da war und da hat er
dann später bisher erfahren zu mir
verzählt was er gesehen hat mit der
ausschreibung gegen juden
nun war mein elternhaus geprägt
christlich katholische guten sie die
nationale waren grenzland in der pfalz
war deutscher ich habe wie ein mehr an
die position gegen andere religionen
haus gerannt auch juden selbst habe ich
gar nicht gekannt zu meiner zeit nicht
an bugs kann dich niemand aber dass es
eine schlimme sache sein muss und der
art der reaktion der eltern und freunden
eltern
das haben wir irgendwie gemerkt aber
natürlich nicht reflektiert wenn es
solche erlebnisse zu hause die sie
später den satan prägen lassen von der
gnade der späten geburt ich habe damals
eine für mich ich denke auch insgesamt
wichtige rede in der knesset dem
parlament des staates halten
mit dem grundthema die deutschen und die
juden das was recht ist im deutschen
namen geschah wie geht's weiter haben
dann in diesem zusammenhang gebracht er
muss aber den ganzen verziehen wird
verlautet dass es für mich und für meine
generation wichtig ist die damalige zeit
erlebt hat wachen bewusstsein wir dann
deutlich wacher bewusstsein aber ohne
selbst sind die gefahr zu geraten in
schuld zu geraten ad acta späten geburt
die erfahrung an die nächste generation
weiterzugeben
dieser setzte die nächste enorm positive
reaktionen hervorgerufen
in deutschland ist der wie so häufig
verfälscht wurden verkürzt worden und im
gegenteil verkehrt worden war all just
an dieser bei dieser reise hat mich auch
mein eigenes leben eingeholt ich waren
das war hat ein großes land noch nicht
gemacht vor allem weil schon verbreitet
war ich mental aviv in dem werk gespielt
werden museum über die jüdische diaspora
ein pädagogisch fantastisch gemacht und
gearbeitete arbeit und winden
durchgelaufen geführt worden von einem
früheren offizier wie das auf dieser
liste pensioniert waren einer der chefs
des hauses war und wir haben das alles
durchgegangen und geräte und an der tür
spricht er mich plötzlich deutschland
aber nie foren deutsche vor und sagt
lebt ihrer mutter noch lebt ihn völlig
sprachlos angeguckt sowie kommt hier für
meine mutter
und dann sagt er ich hab mir am montag
bekannt war dass ein israelischer name
das heißt wenn ich wie das früher auf
deutsch sagt wieso haben sie meine
mutter bekannt
wenn man sagt ich hab sie vermutlich
auch bekannt dass kleines kind dann rede
kurzer sinn bei uns in dem stadtstaat
nämlich hersteller und wohnte gab es so
kleine bäckereien und andere geschäfte
und seine eltern hatten dort eine
bäckerei und sie damit unsere 37
herausgekommen ist soeben das war damals
hat die zeit bei juden kauft man echte
war für meine mutter einen grund für
diesen jüdischen becker zu kaufen
und da war es sicherlich als kind gelegt
nicht dabei
und der hatte danach den namen und nach
dem geburtstag nach dem geburtsort kampf
richtig vermutet dass jemand aus der
siebte sein muss mich dann gefragt dann
habe ich so oft für mich wenn ich
darüber nachdachte auch gesagt meine
mutter hätte auch ganz anders reagieren
können und ist ein weiterer beweis für
meine lebenserfahrung dass uns sich im
leben zweimal zieht und beim ersten mal
daran denken sollen
wie man beim zweiten mann aussieht sagt
ich meine mutter die damals nicht mehr
lebte sehr genossen wetter wenn hier die
geschichte erzählen findet in tel aviv
an gut erzählen dass ihr vater 1940
erzählt hat von denen ausschreitungen
gegen polen wenn sie sagen das damals
eigentlich die meisten in deutschland
hätten wissen können was da so passiert
ich glaube absolut dass kann man das
wirklich nicht sagen
zunächst einmal war mein vater in einer
wüste als offizieren das war glaube ich
pensions- kommentierte kurze zeit in
einer bestimmten funktionen an
bestimmten ort echt cover allerdings
dass im laufe des krieges viele ziehen
können wenn in einer stadt wie die chips
haben wir hier eine kleine jüdische
gemeinde war aber wenn ich über
reingehen hat man einmal eine große
jüdische gemeinde in frankfurt und in
berlin wird sich alle juden
abtransportiert und war konnte man das
schönste ihnen dass hier etwas passiert
ich glaube schon dass die kenne ich
dessen was dann als vorspann geschah bei
viel weniger bekommt waren aber das
männchen abtransportiert wurden
und das allen baganda krücken zum dort
seine skepsis angebracht war
das ist ja dass sein da ich glaube im
übrigen wenn sie einmal die berichte der
gestapo nachlesen
die gis da war die ein unglaublich
intensives spitzelsystem aufgebaut
welche pfarrer welche predigt am sonntag
und dabei auch immer die rede von
stimmung was die bevölkerung sagt welche
das wenn man nachricht lasten einzelner
regionen ich habe das für meine eigene
heimat angetan
damit wird faszinierend wie genau die
wussten was für eine stimmung unter den
leuten waren ist nicht nach oben
weitergegeben worden
und da war natürlich schon auch immer
wieder zu lesen dass dieses verstritten
der juden das abgeordneten leute
beruhigt so schildert es zum beispiel
ihre schwester waren als junger schüler
schon eigentlich immer so ein rad
anführer
sie sagt die haben dann immer bischof
gespielt mit einer kaffee drauf und im
bett lag und die anderen mussten das
bettlaken übertragen also sie waren
immer schon so wenige der vorneweg
wahrheit also das bild das ich so nicht
in erinnerung habe meine schwester hat
es sicher besser beobachtet weiß dass
ich meine ganze schulzeit hindurch eine
rolle wenn sie so wollen als anführer
hatte dass meine schulfreunde kollegen
sie versammelt haben wir kein zufall
dass wir bis zum heutigen tag lag bisher
schönster rapid uns jedes jahr ende
januar treffen und einen unheimlichen
zusammenhalt haben in unserer klasse
wohl das leben uns kommt anderswo
verweht hat das hat auch was mit bezug
zu bier zu tun sich und wir haben dann
nach kriegsende zeit auf dem bauernhof
gearbeitet
warum eigentlich
ja ich habe den weg erstens wusste man
nicht gekriegt wenn wir wie das
weitergeht mit dem gymnasium das
gymnasium habe ich auch nicht über
ausgereizt
und da war so eine idee ob ich jetzt
nicht
landwirtschaft später studieren wollte
zu einem rußfilter dass sie dessen
zugegeben unterfränkischen aber längst
erkannt da waren die blumen landwirte
die aus dem osten kamen und als knecht
auf dem hof gearbeitet haben
das beinamen bedenken ist nur johnson
gab in diesem hoch noch zu realisieren
bevor das später so aber sie ist meine
neigung gebieten dafür bauer zu werden
statt kind hängt das zusammen waren
verhältnis zur natur und zu tieren
das war eine sache die ich immer mit
einer gewissen sympathie betrachtet habe
aber ich habe gar nicht die chance
gehabt
sie haben dann die besatzungszeit lebt
und zuerst was amerikanischen
französischen das veränderte sich eine
stimmung schon nicht ja natürlich die
front die amerikaner kamen im märz 1900
dabei ich ein bestes gaben
1945 nach wirklich sagen haben sich
sofort um den aufbau gekümmert sie waren
sozusagen die sieger müssen sind es war
dass es hat ihn selbst nichts gefehlt
und dann kam ich einen sommer events
ohne der beschlüsse von potsdam die
franzosen mit einem eigenen gebiet
seinen eigenen besatzungs gebiet sie was
von so waren wahrheit bislang reaktionen
heute weiß man dass damals wusste man
dass nicht die reaktionen davon zwischen
bevölkerung an weihnachten 1945
betrachten dagegen auch miserabel und
die französische besatzungszone war
natürlich besonders abgeschlagen bei uns
kam noch in so einem fall dass die
erinnerung an die letzte aktion nämlich
nach dem ersten weltkrieg etwa bei
meinen eltern und beiden älteren maler
präsent waren und auch die erfahrung des
separatismus
es ist schwer vorstellbar was war schon
so dass nicht mehr nach dem ersten
weltkrieg muss ja die tendenz gab das
linke rheinufer abzutreten zu fahrgast
geschlagen
in erinnerungen napoleon und das
departement monten er auch nach dem
zweiten weltkrieges gab es gab die
entwicklungen das war die regierung von
johannes hoffmann die abtrennung der
fahrer und es gab sehr starke die liste
paris bis hin zu schalten und versprach
bürger redet abtrennung des linken
rheinufers bis koblenz die pfalz und
diesen teil deutschlands zu vom geist zu
schlagen und meine erste politische
begegnungen sie so wollen
es gibt aber zu keiner parteien war im
hause eines politischen ziehvaters eines
katholischen pfarrers ab die gespräche
mit der nummer 16 der separatisten der
separatist wie man sich ein igel und
zwar jetzt sich nach parteien sondern
die parteien die später parteien wurden
spd kpd und cdu wir sind in diesen
politischen kreis gelangt was
interessiert das pop doch vor seinem
elternhaus hier und unser pfarrer hat
mir eines tages gesagt du bist doch
interessiert ich war nicht so
interessiert an der sonstigen
jugendarbeit der pfarrer fink in limburg
auf das ist ein ort neben wirklich
schaffen
der verrat junge leute und rudi für den
fall dass dann parteien zugelassen
werden
das war ein großartiger mann das war
damals der wichtigste politiker in der
pfalz war schon vor 1933 abgeordneter
gewesen im zentrum war der hort des
widerstands auch gegen ticker es sind
alle parteien es war wie ein riesiger
bei ihnen verkehr und dann bin ich da
raus gefahren mit dem fahrrad
und an alle 14 tage drei wochen im
wohnzimmer bei dem im pfarrhaus und so
10 12 15
die waren fast alle so anfang 20 mitte
zwanzig übrigens wiederum der typisch
leutnant der heimgekommen war die jetzt
studenten waren ich war das völlig
apathisch der jüngste mit 16 17
aber simon akzeptiert er werde
akzeptiert und das war natürlich ein
ganz wichtiger punkt es gab dort was
wusste brot zu essen oder ein stück
kuchen und dann hat man am tisch sitzen
die wohnzimmer immer einer referiert ich
weiß noch bernhard ich mein erstes
referat war über christlichen
sozialismus ich ein bisschen in die
anderen zu behörden und danach ist
kritisiert worden und daraus ist das ein
sehr starkes engagement erwachsenen 2
stand 2 740 dabei die partei gegründet
damals 17 hatte mit 19 jahren als als
oberprimaner bei der bundestagswahl an
diesem 14
august um eine tomate konnten an dollar
am freitag vor der wahl reden
er war in einem ort um eine frau das war
meine tanzten damen befristet anzuheben
damals als flüchtlinge oder ganz
schwierige werden und das lob hatten
aber ich konnte keine großen sprüche
dort von die war auch nicht in der
versammlung und so war das kein brot
aber war meine erste versammlung aber
sie haben eigentlich sicher vor eine
junge union iju anorganisch die union
die nach der partei gegründet worden ist
47 8 und 14 weitere junge union dann
sind sie wahrscheinlich parteimitglied
gewonnen bevor man damit geht werden
durfte der wahrscheinlich war es gab
aber würden sie das war nicht so
die parteimitglieder das war ja alles
vor der währungsreform werden sie nicht
vergessen das war nicht an zustand wo
man glauben konnte dass das jetzt alles
bürokratischer das so zugeht mein vater
war auch gründungsmitglied
und die haben ihm an der parade der
alten der junge chor unterschiede da für
sie eigentlich da als sie dann als
oberprimaner schon bei rede gehalten
haben das wirklich über bei redner der
haupttäter war im 24
sie mussten sowie beim boxkampf von
handwerk der inhalte werden
das war die wahl erfolgt das war die
erste bundestagswahl und die dürfen
nicht vergessen ich komme wieder auf das
operativ muss zurück diese
bundestagswahl war für uns in der pfalz
ein gewaltiger befreiungsschlag wie man
heute sagen wörtern weiß damit glaube
zwar ist deutschland und das geteilte
deutschland aber an größte französische
der amerikanischen besatzungszone sie
bilden jetzt ein teil deutschlands der
separatismus von diesem zeitpunkt an weg
und sie die auch nicht vergessen dass er
damals so alles unter verbot stand ich
erinnere mich dass ich mit freunden die
schule schwänzen und die einzige
großkundgebung der cdu mit vorbereiten
haus landes war der einzige seite nach
alten war romy der eröffnung als
schlussredner dieser kundgebung dahin
die total überfüllte hinein rief dort
oben sitzt da was man eh von der
französischen besatzung der hat uns
verboten die nationalhymne zu singen wir
sind das deutsche team und wohl der
besucher natürlich ist das ganze
deutschland sieht aber nicht die ziele
jetzt dass man groß deutschland machen
muss sondern das war voller rührung
voller emotionen und dann war ich auch
dabei
bei der ersten wahl auch eröffnungs
kundgebung was wir dann ab 43 die cdu
mahnt dortmund gemacht hatten
49 19 und erwartet die eröffnung auf dem
hambacher schloss und dann weiß ich noch
daran die großen honorationen on demand
aufgeführt
dann habe ich einen herrn haus geführt
von dem ich nur wusste dass er eine
wichtige rolle gespielt
aber sie hat ihr von dem sonst nichts
wusste größter feind
es gibt ja auch die erzählung dass sie
dann mal als noch schüler glaube ich
grenzfälle ausgerissen haben wir
verachten sie ja wir neben dem partei
haben wir eine arbeitsgemeinschaft
europäische wirklichkeit und
anspruchsvoller ging es nicht mehr
gegründet mit schülern und studenten der
tag ganz klar für uns die alternativen
europa das ich bis zu meinem heutigen
lebens tag so geblieben hat auch was
wiederum mit dem grenzland zu tun noch
immer bei weißenburg die jungen eltern
standen am welt wähler rausgerissen und
bedrohung dieses war nach der werden
verfolgen und haben gesungen und sammler
warnte volcker überzogen jetzt ist
europa da viele videos später stand ich
mit frau zu mir an dieser stelle ich
habe ihnen gehört in die geschichte
erzählt und an diesem tag haben wir
trotzdem ein stück geschichte
eingeschrieben
das war nämlich der tag an dem wir die
letzte vereinbarung trafen dass die
letzten reste der deutschen
auseinandersetzungen
was die was die grundstücke an der
grenze betrifft bis hin zur
evangelischen kirche in paris dass das
wieder an die deutschen zurück gegeben
wird und da waren wir bei dieser
gelegenheit an dieser stelle gestanden
ich habe das sehr viel sinn für so was
hat sie waren also ganz über der partei
dabei was war für sie die partei damals
war das für sie sozusagen die
organisation die sie zu macht führen
würde - also das steht auch in den
büchern ich sitze also schon sozusagen
in den liebesbriefen an meiner
freundin tanzstunden wärme und später
darüber gefahr für das die dazu oder
unsinn
die partei war für mich eigentlich die
möglichkeit politisch tätig zu sein
ich komme die stadtwirtschaft war ihm
eine rote stadt herzberg lieben ihn
versuchungen nein da war ich also vom
elternhaus dagegen gefeit und doch gab
es dazu dient mir ich bin ja nicht in
einer abneigung hat zu morden oder so
sondern die waren eben ganz anders ihm
in bestimmten in einer bestimmten weise
und so weich hatte das gericht für mich
eine überlegung was die partei betrifft
und dann habe ich natürlich in der
partei von der pike auf gelernt was man
so lernt wie man eben den ortsausschuss
kommt gewählt wird und so weiter und so
weiter
und das hat mich natürlich schon sehr
stark geprägt auch die programmatische
diskussion die damals hier ganz anders
lief und bei plakate kleben haben sie
sich ab und zu mal mit dem plakat geber
der anderen
das war dass es war umgangsstil den
kommen sie auch also nicht vorstellen
es gab es den civic darf man als
schwarzer gar nicht im grunde bei tag
und da gab es auch immer embl ein
erzkörper stehen die diskrete das
eröffnungsstück weimar hast du das spiel
ja sozusagen ein friedberger erlitten
aber die älteren haben hier noch zum
teil weimar erlebt viele leute die
damals geplante risikoarm warten hier
schon vertrauen kreist um an dem
stadtrat aber ist das auch etwas was in
ihrer natur ist mal ein bisschen laufen
denn es ist die berühmte szene wo er in
halle jemandem auf sie wirken sie dann
vergattert im karlsteiner also dass ich
früher einer rauferei nicht auf dem weg
ins war aber das ist schon lange her das
sind habe seinen ganz anderen sache in
halle bin ich ausgestiegen und der stadt
eine große zahl älterer frauen und und
ich rede mit denen dann ziehe ich den
schritt entfernung von 56 metern wie
einer mit so ner kiste anfängt eier zu
werfen
jetzt mal an den kopf gekriegt haben
damals musste ich noch eine brille
tragen meine haben sind ja inzwischen
besser geworden das brauche ich nicht
mehr
dann ist sehr unangenehm es in der
brille haben kriegen eier an den kopf
leicht natürliche ängste haben und
dadurch alles ihm zwar immer meine
devise nicht vor bränden auf den
losgehen und ich doch leider sind nicht
erwischt haben
wir hatten als politiker haben sie
gerade gesprochen ein ziehvater denn die
kann fink aber sie haben eigentlich
sonst immer eher das image das sie mehr
der enkel waren ja das war heute mein
image oder man zustimmen das war der
zustand meiner altersgruppe
wir wollen die tüchtige wie die heute 25
jährigen dass das blitzen wenn man sich
das ein bildet das würden sie wenn sie
1955 in die politische arena deutschland
schauten ob bundestag oder landtag oder
kommunalpolitik dabei eine ganze
generation wechselt zu fall des die drei
prägenden figuren des neubeginns der
deutschen demokratischen parteien täler
als konrad adenauer und kurt schumacher
er alle drei aus dem teils völlig in
deutschland kamen
krömer war schon reich werk von
abgeordneten kriegsteilnehmer mathworks
kultur aber nicht bei der weimarer
republik heißt es abgeordnete aber war
redakteur abnahme munition
oberbürgermeister 1917 in köln
und hier der ice war dozent ebenfalls
von 1914 diamanten sozusagen die
geschichte ganz anders mitgebracht als
ich in den landtag kam haben wir sieben
abgeordnete die früher im reichstag war
das was wird wenn die generation meines
vaters und dadurch sei eine ganze
generation weggeschossen waren zwar
brutal auszudrücken krieg geblieben war
oder durch einen
entwicklung der nazizeit nicht mehr in
der lage war weiter politisch tätig zu
sein weil sie in ihrem lebenslauf hier
einen einen einbruch erlitten hatten
haben wir jungen ganz ungewöhnlich viele
chance bekommen und das sind wir auch
nicht besser wenn sie wollen mit
paradebeispiel
aber ich bin ich da einzige sehr jungen
wichtigen bankengruppe das war nicht
normal es war bloß eine lücke im abfolge
der generation darf wir haben studiert
in heidelberg kleines weiter vorne
verloren hat und in heidelberg aber wir
haben ihr studium selber verdient als
stein schleifer gibt wenn sie dafür habe
ich zu hause wohnenden fordern hatte ich
aber im haushalt eines staatssekretärs
waren keine reichtümer aber ich hatte
alles was ich brauchte zum leben
ich bin dann war dann fahrschüler wenn
sie so gar kein problem volle bedarf
nach heidelberg
also dann zone roller und dann habe ich
viele jahre danach sehr geliebt aber
bisher mobil gemacht
und dann habe ich gesungen gerechnet
über die ferienzeit immer gearbeitet
dreieinhalb jahre steifer das war in den
der steinhauer wo die steinmetzen sind
eher wurden für die bestimmten
bedingungen der chemischen industrie für
bestimmte kanäle für säuren oder bars
oder normale ab aber nicht benutzen kann
hergerichtet und das war der eigentliche
steirer das von anderen beruf wieso
wildtiere h2 preise eben nach dem
gleichen prinzip wenn ein modell gebaut
wurde
warum man noch nicht gross zu später wie
das im großversuch aussieht ist es im
kleinen versuch dargestellt worden hat
man beispielsweise schieferplatten
trotzdem klappen in einem bestimmten maß
maßstäben zu bestücken
und da habe ich für als sehr gut
verdient und war in einem arbeitsbereich
wir waren zwei studenten waren voll
integrierte die
ferienzeit urlaub kämpft mit uns
gerechnet
wenn ich kam an die kollegen waren sehr
hat sie zweitens war der einzige
schwarze deswegen sehr historische wahl
redner dass wir uns nicht vergessen oder
sie sehr goutiert worden um ihm auf den
aufgezogen worden ich habe
zurückgeschlagen
aber wenn ich kam habe ich jetzt einige
stunden für den accord von dem gekriegt
damit gleich in die höchste stufe kam
wenn ich dann fertig war am ende der
ferien habe ich wieder den wieder
zurückgegeben
ich bin da noch viele jahre später auch
noch als minister brillen denn dies war
dann niemand mehr da bin ich bin mit dem
damals geschäfte betreffen wo heute team
immer wieder wenn ich gewählt es besucht
hatte wie vor in meiner werkstatt
gegangen und dann haben wir außerhalb
der bewegungs regen
der oberste boss und der
ministerpräsident in meinem auto bewegen
ein anständiges bier verzichtet wir
haben studiert obwohl dieser bewährten
selbst das gymnasium wenn ich etwas das
was sie besonders angetan hat aber für
youtube gibt es nicht aber
leidenschaftlich gern studiert so
umgänglich die schule bin gern habe ich
studiert und habe weil ich ja selber das
mit finanziert habe auch nie den drang
verspürt jetzt morgen fertig zu werden
nach dem wahnsinnig viel gelernt ich
studium ich lebe ich bis zum heutigen
tag davon der sich gelegen nicht mehr
überlegen was war da und nachgucken
ich habe also ein paar jahren gestorben
90 mit meinem doktorvater immer noch
kontakt gehabt weil der peter fuchs ja
ich habe berichtet françois mitterrand
oft darüber geredet meine kenntnisse
französische geschichte unendlich viel
geholfen obwohl es eigentlich von mir
gesehen er war nicht vorgesehen aber das
war eine sache nicht aus neigung gemacht
der theologie philosophie
das hat mir alles nicht geschadet ich
bin dafür dass man als student vor allem
wenn man
öffentliche gelder in anspruch ist es
nicht getan woran macht mit dem studium
aber ich musste ihn ganz offen sagen wer
die gelegenheit wird zum studium
generale wirklich zu erfahren
eine vergleichbare chancen ihm liegen
die sie nie mehr in einem
lebensabschnitt wo sie zwar aufnehmen
oder einem guten ziel ist es wahr dass
neugierige sagen ich habe es nie bereut
wenn sie deswegen sagen auch studenten
leuten heute sich ein bisschen zeit
nehmen um mehr zu lernen breiter ich
würde es anders er ist meine studenten
sollen sich zeit nehmen wirklich breit
informiert zu sein wenn sie allerdings
dann öffentliche gelder ganz andere
sache
am sonntag überlegen dass sie natürlich
eine bringschuld haben
aber wenn jemand wenn jemand sagt also
dass uns immer auf die kante abgemessen
zeit und er tut überhaupt nicht über das
eigentliche vaschem wichtiges brot
studium hinaus finde ich das schade
eigentlich finde ich sollte man der
studiert am ende im guten alten wortsinn
ein gebildeter mensch sein war nur da
frau wobei ich jetzt sich
bildungsakademie studie beziehen wenn
sie einen qualifizierten
schreinermeister vor sich sehen und
ziehen was er kann ist das ein
hochgebildeter mann während des studiums
haben sie aber politische arbeit
betrieben ja und was war daher an dass
sie gesagt haben also ich möchte weiter
kommen ich möchte einmal positionen
übernehmen und verantwortungen also das
weiß ich nicht ob man das so sagen kann
das wird wird so angedichtet
ich war nun wenn sie so wollen
in der sache drin ich bin mit real mit 3
24 jahren den geschäftsführenden cdu
vorstand der pfalz kommt es war ein
wichtiges an
die junge union sondern ataka partei
viel jünger salon war sie mitten im
getriebe er werde er auch früh am tag
kommen wenn es abgelehnt weil der
altmodischen richtigen meinung auch
heute bietet meine meinung war die
verwirrt waren meine ausbildung
abschließen
es war uns damals auch so dass man da
kaum eine chance hatte ohne
abgeschlossene ausbildung und dann war
ich noch mal hörst assistent und dann
will ich ja eher zum gummi verband hat
und die chemische industrie in berlin
oder bei sehr kurzen moment genießen
verband nein ich habe den verband arbeit
habe ich mitgemacht lang
fraktionsvorsitzender als
berufspolitiker geworden und die
minister den boden
sie waren aber sehr schnell
fraktionsvorsitzende heißt sie hatten
auch schon ein netzwerk an politischen
freunden gebildet ja obwohl das band in
der fraktion mit figur wirklich war mit
weitem abstand der jüngste
nein in der fraktion war es ganz
eindeutig so dass wir die cdu dringend
wird zum thema wie konfessionsschulen
waren dem mann von allergrößter dann
wären die konzessionsabgabe war später
sollte themen waren heftig umstritten
von rheinland pfalz weil er sich vom
himmel gefallen sondern
zusammengewachsen und sehr
unterschiedlichen gebieten in früheren
preußischen tagen im norden des landes
frühere volksstaat hessen und die
frühere bayerische pfalz der kanzlerin
diesen fragen sie oder sittliche
meinungen bei der in der gleichen cdu
sehr viel mehr die ein integraler wird
man heute sagen und die anderen mehr
nach der anderen seite stärker liberalen
so verstanden liberalen pfalz und und
ich hatte dann natürlich als ich in den
landtag kam stand ich gerne noch völlig
neue generation
aber ich wäre ohne diese altersgruppe
wurde sprachen die fraktionsvorsitzender
geworden und dadurch etwas passiert dass
der damalige fraktionsvorsitzende der
schon vor dreiunddreißig preußische
landtag
dr boten starb auch in den 70 und hatte
sozusagen in der botschaft die war nicht
war überhaupt nicht wissen
grund unserer demnach den eher im
gegenteil weiß der frisch war dass dafür
der dann bedingt ihm gehabt
mit recht wie ich möchte frei der hat
aber eine botschaft an takt
fraktionskollegen gebieten
sie sollten den jüngsten wählen so einen
bewussten jüngst wlan signal zu geben
für die veränderungen die jetzt eintritt
das hat er wird heute wird man sagen von
toten wird diese botschaft ausgehen
lassen
ja mich gewählt aber der
ministerpräsident einmal war ich an
damals aber völlig anderer meinung war
ganz zu recht erkannt dass der helmut
rollen in bestimmten fragen die
konfession zu einer völlig anderen kurs
vertreten hat und er war natürlich auch
anders geprägt erzählt bär war natürlich
auch vor dreiunddreißig ratsmitglied
werden dieses jahr 100 jahre alt dann
können sie die distanz erkennen und der
große leistungen rheinland pfalz
gebracht aber es war eben jeder weise
eine andere zeit er hat sich vielleicht
auch angst gehabt dass da einer kommt
den fertigen könnte das sicherlich auch
dass wir ganz normal aber jeder andere
der gekommen wären wir ja vermutlich
kein nachfolger geworden
aber die verfolger deutlich zulegt sonst
ganz sicher nicht gewünscht erst am ende
seines lebens war dann glücklich und
zufrieden und ich weiß noch dass wir uns
auf franz josef röder der damalige
ministerpräsident da sein so am arm
genommen cappella du bist der einzige
des nachfolger bundeskanzler wird
und das war dann für ihn schon daran ein
argument aber wir waren natürlich schon
waren zwei welten zwar erfüllt unsere
generation
und wir haben ja auch fast aus dem amt
gedrängt hatte wäre eine fahrmanöver
zwar immer verbreitet
also wir haben eine abmachung 1967
das war schon 65 hab ich gesagt ich will
jetzt gar ministerpräsident werden aber
beeilen und der mitte der nächsten
periode 2006 trat ja auch ein
aber leute das aber nicht unbedingt dann
zudem zeit zu dem zeitpunkt
er war über 20 jahre bei uns insofern
war das keine zu kurze amtszeit
und das wollte er nicht
und es war eine kurze aber untereinander
sitzung aber gottseidank und ab das
freut mich heute noch bisschen wir nicht
in diesem leben auseinander gegangen in
feindschaft sondern in einer sehr
freundschaftlichen beziehung und ich
werde ein paar monaten ausgesprochen
gerne in seinen in einer veranstaltung
zur erinnerung am peter altmeier
zusammen hundertsten geburtstags frösche
haben das nie gehabt dass jemand
gekommen das sind sie sozusagen gedacht
hätte der nächsten periode ist schluss
aber können sie verstehen dass es sein
dann wenn man dann dem moment kommt wie
altmaier dass man über geben muss dass
das wir natürlich gern zu verstehen die
fünfziger sechziger jahre war geprägt
von adana und er hat haben sie
eigentlich an neues politik der
westbindung auch zurzeit der stalin note
immer unterstützt dadurch
nierenproblemen gehabt mein problem den
mauern anderes war ein prozess warten ab
noch am anfang ich war ein überzeugter
anhänger von al qaida weil ich habe eben
von der öffnung des wahlkampfs 49
geredet das waren leute die für mich
mitten im leben standen der partner
waren als der alte adenauer bei einer
betrachtungsweise ich war da nicht
allein
ich habe dann
begegnet mit ihm gehabt dass auch eine
sehr interessante sachen ich hab auch
ein bundesparteitag 253 war
widersprochen und wobei nicht weiß ich
gar nicht mehr genau was es war
ich war sehr schnell und sehr frech
beweglich dann mit den bemerkungen und
und viele wochen später bekam ich einen
anruf ich hatte gar kein telefon zu
hause über die cdu geschäften hat damals
ein minister namens glocke da war noch
kein staatssekretär geforscht nach dem
jungen groß und dann habe ich
zurückrufen
anders gesagt der alte herr möchte ich
möchte den alten herrn besuchen und so
weit zu merkt man ein leben mit drei
oder vier und 20 jahren hier in diesem
haus und das war jeder weise über
meldeten adenauer hier im kanzleramt und
dann war noch etwas
das wollte er war er war ja von einer
bestechenden höflichkeit ich der junge
tot ist völlig klar dass er an der tür
wartete mandant und man entwickelt sich
gebracht und hat sich dann erkundigt was
sie zu drei wochen so weiter wollte was
eigentlich wollte ist was ist das schön
kann aber natürlich vorher das ist auch
klar
erkundigungen eingezogen gehabt meine
kirche im landesverband und so weiter
und so hat sich das alles entwickelt
bis zum letzten freitag auf was
antwortet ihm telefoniert haben haben
sie daraus auch dieses moment gezogen
dass sie sich um sehr junge leute können
ja das habe ich immer gemacht wenn das
mache ich auch jetzt nachdem ich von
amtspflichten befreit bin investieren
bewusst sagen dass hier eine bestimmte
zeit weit ich eben findet das ist unser
job
wenn man lebenserfahrung hatte sich
übertragen das natürliche von eltern im
verhältnis zu kindern das rad wirklich
jeden tag neu erfunden aber umgekehrt
müssen die jungen ihren beitrag wie sie
das rad auf strafen interpretieren jeden
tag neu finden und das habe ich immer
getan und war dabei eigentlich jetzt
erfolgreich mehr nachweisbar
wobei eben für mich eben jugend sei
nicht mehr die frage der jahre ist gibt
ja ganz schrecklich alte junge leute
aber es gibt auch dem regiert man zu
adenauer anderer soll er dann gesagt
haben irgendwas in mir vorstellen dass
jemand wie hatte meine sache fortführt
beim jetzt wird überhaupt also ich gehe
dann zu erinnern und ich nicht mehr
angesprochen ich weiß ich weiß nur als
landesparteivorsitzender ein
unfallfahrer geredet du tust du fußball
damals firma parteivorsitzender war mehr
ein wirklich väterlicher freund und es
wird es ab 9 fuß war zu jener zeit nicht
das allerbeste und der duh fuß hat sehr
freundlich über mich im beisein von
opfern geredet nacheinander weg
engagiert zu meiner wahl als nachfolger
als parteivorsitzender und
ministerpräsident und der hat so etwas
zu ihm gesagt und später ist gar keine
frage das war mir dann wiederum später
dass er so in seinen vorstellungen einer
vorstellung hatte aus dem könnte was
werden
das team aus chemiker umfeld zusammen
ein mann wie heinisch krone der die
partei sehr gut konnte demnach stand der
hatte ausgesprochen haben hat mich
freundschaftlich begleitet das war mit
dem ich am ende ganz eng befreundet was
seines lebens der nicht zu eng wiederum
mit dem markt war
aber wir sind sozusagen die großen alten
leute
wenn es so zu nennen in einem umfeld
über den jungen reden und sie reden
durchaus auch mal in einer aufbauenden
weise ist es schon hilfreich und das
habe ich dir erlebt ich habe viel grund
den alten zu danken die dem ganz jungen
war nicht eben auch den vorerwähnten
verpissen sehr viel jünger war
dann sind kann man mindestens dutzend
nennen die mir geholfen haben
wenn man diese ist er ja sieht dann war
ja da das wichtige probleme der wieder
nachfolger von anna schröder oder er hat
auf wessen seite an seite stand auf
ihren fall da einfach nicht wieder
einzig der bessere sondern ist anständig
wie sie wir haben mit dem er die
wettkämpfe gemacht
für mich war dass wir nie eine sache in
den politologischen seminar sondern ich
bin mit dem er hat durch die gegend
gezogen der in der pfalz war der bezirk
sitzen in der pfalz und das war der
wahlkämpfer dem war nie was zu viel und
es war einfach für mich
selbstverständlich ob er der richtige
kanzler war
und ich möchte sie später zeigten das
war ja und so nicht irgendwie viel zu
weit weg der nicht zu nah dran aber das
war ganz klar dass ich diesem
zusammenhang auf die seite von di hat
stand ich habe es einfach als anständig
empfunden für jahr zu sein
sie waren ja in den 50er jahren kurzer
zeit mal gegen die wiederbewaffnung
warum eigentlich
ich war nicht gegen die wiederbewaffnung
ist war in der frage des zeitpunktes
gehört zu denen die natürlich noch alles
im ohr hatten und auch selber gesagt
haben nie wieder
und es war natürlich auch rechte leute
in der cdu wird leidet die aus einer
überzeugten christlichen haltung heraus
diese position vertreten waren und es
ist ja nett
eher normalen ein junger nicht zu sechs
pragmatisch denke er hat kommen hat sie
bei ihm auch beeinflusst dass er so
stark für die soziale jahr
das ist mit dem heutigen datum geblieben
ich mag überhaupt ist es gibt ganz
wenige punkte wo ich mich wirklich rd
und dazu gehört wenn man denn er hat in
anspornen nun redet nur von der
marktwirtschaft
ich habe der ludwig erhard erlebt in
vielen situationen bis hin zu zahlen
ende seiner zeit wenn ich an 82 größter
wenig hat dann die veranstaltung
mitgestaltet habe als parteivorsitzender
zwischenzeit der für der ludwig erhard
war das immer eine sache wo er soziale
marktwirtschaft er immer gesagt der
status rahmenbedingungen setzen die
rahmenbedingungen müssen optimal seien
für freiheit und der fahrer entwicklung
aber sprachen zu einer verantwortung von
den leuten wenn der wirklich er den ein
oder anderen heute dazu fernsehen sehen
jürgen der als der unternehmer mit
ständer stimme verkündet ich leide jetzt
ausgestellt werden
das war nicht seine welt und was er
wirklich er hat natürlich immer aber ist
ein mann der ihre welt ein mann der es
nicht stand so nicht wenn man da
großindustrie und da bin ich ein treuer
er hat jana geblieben
aber wenn sie gerade den jetzigen
zustand kritisieren ist das eigentlich
noch die soziale marktwirtschaft geehrt
die forscher die vielleicht auch sie
sich vorstellen
ich hatte absolut für notwendig und
richtig dass er heute noch soziale
marktwirtschaft unter den veränderten
verhältnissen aber will hier früheren
hintern jemand so betrieben ist das
nicht mehr so die shareholder berliner
der musiker zu sagen wird unser gespräch
eine tänzerin die sich akzeptieren
es gibt nicht die unternehmer es gibt
nicht die journalisten gibt die unsere
es gibt nicht die politik es gibt
sanktionen sollte wenn ich meine
lebensweg betrachte habe ich in groß-
und kleinbetrieben fantastische
patriotisch gesonnene unternehmer erlebt
die gesagt haben ich mache das um so
wichtig an meine leute mir hat man eine
firma vor mir einer der migros 100 in 7
der ein großes familienunternehmen führt
über ein vorstandsvorsitz seiner anderen
großen unternehmen aber dann gerät sagt
er das sowieso denkt an seine pension
ich denke meine enkel in betrieb wenn
sie heute erleben dass es unternehmer
oder manager gibt dass es leute gibt die
der funktion ja die sagen oh gott ich
kann auch den firmensitz ins ausland
verlegen oder durch die globalisierung
sehr viel mehr an den vermied firmen
profit denken als an das soziale in der
marktwirtschaft wenn sie da sagen dass
eine entwicklung die sie gerne sehen ja
ich glaube nicht dass das so pauschal
gesagt wird aber will ich jetzt nicht
konzentriere auf die beispiele die sie
sagten dann bin ich absolut der meinung
das sind richtig bei einer vorstellung
von sozialer marktwirtschaft ich glaube
auch nicht dass es funktioniert
ich kann nirgends so als hätte man ihm
an amerika funktioniert die
amerikanische politische und ökonomische
probier seine völlig anders und ich kann
jetzt nicht ein taler ausreißt und bei
uns antworten ich glaube schon dass das
wissen wir über gehen nicht auf den
misthaufen der geschichte gelandet mit
diesem system mit sind nach den usa
im weltmaßstab numero zwei export und
wenn ich in einer reihe von diensten von
star zur regierungschefin auf dieser
erde nennen wo das gilt von ludwig
erhard hängt und die haben sich ja was
dabei gedacht und sagen der mann hat
eine vision gehabt werde umgesetzt mit
allen stärken und schwächen auch
gleichzeitig und wer jetzt zur
nachforschung und sagt es hätte das
alles nicht gegeben
wer keine ahnung von der jüngsten
geschichte und deswegen will ich
leidenschaftlich dafür die lehre wird in
beiden teilen zu bejahen die soziale
verantwortung und die verantwortung für
eine freiheitliche gesellschaft dog dass
wir im bereich der sozialen dimension
die grenzen des vernünftigen
überschritten haben besteht ja heute
vernünftig heute kein mensch mehr
das heißt aber nicht einmal das opfer
kosten nur ein stück der normalisierung
ich glaube auch nicht dass all die die
jetzt sagen wir machen das alles
weltweit fünf jahren noch das gleiche
sachen werden das kann man mit hoher
abwarten auch in der wirtschaft gibt es
moden die kommen und die gehen dass
große unternehmen weltweit operieren ist
völlig klar wenn ich ein weltkonzern
führen muss ich wissen dass ich ohne
produktionsstätte in indien oder der
volksrepublik china das ich machen kann
und hier zu hause in mutterbetrieb muss
ich wissen dass das konsequenzen hat
aber ich glaube ich daran dass große
wirtschaftsunternehmen weltweit
operieren können und gastieren
stammbetrieb auf das glaub ich nicht
später die technische innovation noch
vieles andere
das muss man einfach mit in ihrer
schlimmsten aber der großteil der leute
die unternehmerisch tätig sind
die haben wir die chance noch das wollen
die so zu verhalten
sie sind 69 ministerpräsident geworden
rheinland pfalz und zwei jahre später
haben sie schon für den nächsten schritt
versucht nämlich parteivorsitzender zu
werden
warten sie ja zuerst die überlegung dass
sie das vielleicht so aufteilen früher
da wird der kanzlerkandidat und sie der
parteivorsitzender schröder wollte da
nicht mitspielen warum nicht das war ja
auch nicht ganz um nicht wollte doch
partout 900 und zwar 70 ganz
parteivorsitzender werden es wohl gar
kein preis nach bonn zu dieser zeit
konnten wir schon unter 90 angeboten
entweder ins bundeskabinett auf
generalsekretär nach bonn zu kommen das
wollte ich überhaupt nicht
ich war überzeugt bei allem respekt bei
der eigenen leistung dass wir mit rainer
barth und die war gegen wie die brand
nicht gewinnen das war meine position
aber nicht gemein sei eine weit
verbreitete meinung in der partei und
ich habe mich wieder ganz auf das hat
nichts mit gegnerschaft zu tun und meine
idee war nicht nur meine beim ganzer
kreis werde als schröder ist der beste
kanzlerkandidat wird gegen brandt
stellen können und die erfahrung hat ja
auch uns gezeigt am beispiel er hat
später beispiel helmut schmidt über das
jetzige bietet sich treten
das in unseren verhältnissen ein kampf
der nicht ganz fertig parteivorsitz wer
hilft das der schwerste probleme bekommt
deswegen waren wir für den parteivorsitz
und schröder als gewinner ging und für
den kanzlerkandidaten und ich habe
schröder angeboten
neuer stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender
das ist so eine farm zu legen in der
parteiarbeit keine andere funktion
feiern meint minister berlin und mainz
in bonn war keine große problematik der
entfernung und dass ich dann also
sozusagen ihm schon die arbeit schaffe
ich wollte partout kein parteipolitiker
werden unter gerhard schröder war das
sehr mit einverstanden und eines abends
eppstein im fernsehen gehört dass er in
irgendeiner veranstaltung in münchen
verkündet hat er wurde als konzern
verbleiben aber als parteivorsitzender
überhaupt nicht so helmut kohl machen
der würde beste parteivorsitzenden das
war ja gar nicht lang wird ein parteitag
in
in fabriken und verpflichtete sich in
einer bucht forderung zur wichtiger ja
bei dieser entscheidung auf dem
parteitag durch geworden weil keine geht
haben sie trotzdem gerne gutes kommt ja
ich kann dir nicht sagen wie sie das war
nie meine sache zu greifen
wir haben formal falschen kicker ab und
ihm gesagt wir sind dafür dass wachstum
ich parteivorsitzender und ich kann der
kandidat wird conwert hingeht sagen
jetzt haben wir gar keinen kandidaten
und da ist es mir am meisten voll
genommen hatte habe ich hatte mich hin
gestimmt aber wohl wissend dass in der
sache nichts zu gewinnen hat ja doch
nicht gesperrt
nein es war eine lassen dass eine reihe
leute mich vorher scharf gemacht haben
das zu machen was natürlich aber das
liegt zum lesen umgefallen war nur
geschmerzt habe ich unbeschadet damit
überhaupt nichts mit zwei jahre später
war die partie von zwei jahre später war
es wieder ganz anders
er hat weil sie war total verloren gegen
willy brandt einer batterie getreten
ich freue mich noch im 1 karpfen so
fraktionsvorsitzender geworfen und dann
war rudolf widmann im parteivorstand und
hat uns also eine demoskopische kurve
schnitten in der form dass er uns
praktisch jeden zukunft abgesprochen hat
und an dem tag in sachen faz in stelle
ausschreiben könnte siem angemeldete in
der sitzung am schluss sagt gerade jetzt
ist es fertig kandidieren aber das war
nicht einer eigentlich geister und jubel
das jetzt kandidiert sondern das war so
eine grundstimmung
cole phelps aber krawatten sie sagten
muss sein schon zu ihrer zeit als
ministerpräsident rheinland-pfalz
gehörten zu denjenigen die sehr gute
personalauswahl machten also sie haben
roman herzog dahin gezogen
heiner geißler dann hat vogel sie haben
wollen und wie galerien für andere und
sie haben dann auch sowohl biedenkopf
zum generalsekretär gemacht und später
geistern die server zwei leute die dann
eigentlich versucht haben sie zu stürzen
was ist da schiefgelaufen auch das ist
ich würde es auch unterschiedlich den
bei den balten kurt biedenkopf habe ich
im büro der von der borusse
gründungsrektor war dann bei einer
großen firma düsseldorf arbeitete weil
ich jemand der meinung war dass ist
wichtiges leute von draußen rein zu
holen
hanna renate laurien richard von
weizsäcker und des meistens dazwischen
zeit vergessen hat gehörte auch zu den
und ich kann die liste beliebig
fortsetzen und twingo war dann generale
deren als ich nach der wahl 76 hatte
gesagt egal wie die wahl ausgeht ich geh
nach bonn hat er nach einiger zeit
gesagt wenn du da bist entwickelt sich
diese partei arbeitssituation so dass du
eigentlich packen generalsekretär
brauchst und er wolle sich danach die
kraft dann zurückziehen um diese darf
stirnbereich für die cdu die am ende
darf also nrw verloren hat zu bringen
in ordnung zu bringen und daraus ziehen
hat sich schön da sheen hat sich dann
eine ganze menge spannung entwickelt
weil wir in grundsatzfragen ganz anderer
meinung war war immerhin ist es ja eine
tatsache dass 1990 architekt die sachsen
bei mir waren und mir sagt nur ich eine
kandidatur von kurt biedenkopf als
minister burg in sachsen unterstützt
nämlich auch gefragt dass leidenschaft
ich getan habe ein riesen wal kommt
92 49 in einer gasse was eine ganz
andere sache der hat eben zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt den partnern und es
ist ja normal im leben die überzeugend
gewonnen ich sollte weg und andere
sollten kampker werden und er sollte
parteivorsitzender werden dass ein
problem war dass er mit dem
generalsekretär nicht innerlich eine
wurde
er wurde general zeugen nicht weg wird
ihr aber es ist eine mischung
es war halt gegen die ordnung der
parteien auch gegen meine vorstellung
mit bewährter partner meiner mann war
der fehler von geister dass er nicht die
kraft sich den brutus hatte das weiß ich
nicht
ein richtiger der nicht richtiger war
war gar keine frage hat zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt war klar dass er
glaubte er habe mit anderen zusammen die
grafik zu stürzen
ich habe ihn monate vorher gewarnt vor
diesem abenteuer und am abend des
parteitags in bremen hat erkannt dass
die mehrheit die mich fertig und hat
sicherlich auch völlig vergessen dass
sich inzwischen die lage total ihn dann
ab zudem verändert also dürfen ja nicht
vergessen am abend dieses parteitag
genauer gesagt am presseabend vor den
parteitagen am sonntag und die
dramatische auseinandersetzung
innerparteilich war montag bis 19 uhr
der ungarische ministerpräsident vor die
presse getreten und hat gesagt seit 19
uhr ist die grenze zu österreich
geöffnet
diesen termin er war für später
vorgesehen hat ich nehme noch gebeten
gab vorzuverlegen griechen bedarf den
bremen rede von einer sache und tut wie
sich nicht so war das ja mit mir von der
bundesregierung abgesprochen
1976 haben sie für die cdu ein
grandioses ergebnis eingefahren sind
zwar ziemlich kanzler geworden und
anschließend hat franz josef strauß der
große widersacher
derzeit eigentlich mit kreuz gesagt die
csu geht aus der fraktion heraus
sie haben ihm klug begegnen dass die cdu
nach bayern damit war kreuz sterben aber
er hat sie persönlich ja doch sehr
scharf angegriffen in seinem kalten sie
seien nicht fähig so was zu werden und
weiter
haben sie das persönlich übel genommen
sie haben sich nicht provozieren lässt
also zunächst einmal zur 76 komischer
was ich wirklich meine meinung
ich hab ja nur wenige untertauchen
stimme für die mehrheit
ich weiß noch wie die prinzipielle gehen
da war war das thema bundespräsidenten
ich bin vorgestellt worden und dann hat
der herzog von edinburgh gefragt
oppositionsführer
diese sitze im parlament habe ich ihm
das gesamte aber nicht so angekommen und
dann aber dann habe ich ihm gesagt 48,6
das konzept begeistert ein mensch mit 48
gestiegen nachdem britischen wahlrechts
oppositionsführer ist weil der schüler
den bands und der kunden ist ihr bruder
aufgrund seiner eigenen politischen
tätigkeit erklärt warum das so ist
aber im nachhinein dabei zwar das nicht
meine meinung war da ziemlich verbittert
dass das alles nichts genutzt hat weiß
ich will mich damals die 200.000 im
grunde werden ja später kein boxkampf
einer gewissen den das von draußen rein
nach bonn
ohne die entsprechende erfahrung etwa
mit der bonner pressekonferenz um 18
deswegen schief gegangen meinte stein
rheinland pfalz geleitet hatten ja
natürlich und ich habe dann hat ich habe
dann als opposition schwere zeit erlebte
straße dieses abenteuer vom kreuz just
an dem tag gestartet habe wo ich am tag
vor zurückgetreten war also sozusagen
haben ich habe keine absicht gehabt
du kannst zwar gleich gehen weil aber
beide fußballer situation deswegen weil
alle in meinem fast alles was bist du
denn verrückt angefangen von meiner frau
und alle anderen
warum gehst du jetzt nach borns eine
unsichere sache und das war schon ein
hammer diese geschichte diese nacht war
schon glücklich und es war ja auch so
abgesprochen
an der nächste tag war dann schon besser
weiß ich eben zeigte wer alles auch in
der csu in bayern danach neue vom
bankkonto oder benzin armen menschen
kommen wir gehen zu euch und es hat mir
dann schon sehr geholfen und ich habe ja
dann noch von 48 stunden wo wir backen
kelten landesverband der wahl aufzubauen
in münchen mal angefangen büros zu
suchen und das freunde große
pädagogische wir durften aber er hat
trotzdem wir niedergemacht und seinen
teil der franzose beim verhältnis zu ihm
ist sehr einfach zu schildern waren was
wir miteinander erlebt haben haben wir
sozusagen in zwei abteilungen gelebt der
abteilung mit glänzend verstanden haben
in vielen fragen mit ihm unterwegs zu
sein er war mehr viel gemein verwundern
über geschichten anderes zu reden null
probleme miteinander gehabt
in der einzel zum von politik und von
leuten was unterschiedliche wissen
ziehen wenn wir jetzt versucht ihn zu
verstehen ich versuche dass ich bin ja
einer von denen der bis heute noch
verteidigt viele die in vielen verdanken
sind inzwischen die bücher weg gegangen
wenn es darum geht um zu stehen
es bleibt dabei der erst eine der ganz
großen figuren der deutschen
nachkriegspolitik mit einem tragischen
aspekt dass ihr auch zu sein eigenes tun
gelegentlich eigentlich dorthin ich kam
war seine begabung dann können nach
landen müssen und erkennt so kommt das
und es war nicht das was mich betrifft
dass er andere an ihm vorbeizieht und
kanzler wird und der es noch viel jünger
oder gar nicht die brillanz in vielen
punkten wie er viel hatte oder weil sich
das war für ihn schwer erträglich es ist
gar keine frage und sondern auch viele
reden für zeile und wenige bescheid aber
wie sie meine position war immer ganz
klar spiel der viel jüngeren und er war
ganz unbestreitbar eine entscheidende
säule hätte ich mich mit meinem freund
nach kreuz zu dem abenteuer verleiten
lassen wir gehen ab sondern wenn die
diesen zustand sagt man hat gesagt wie
in der wanne republik wahlweise
volkspartei zentrum in berichten
bestimmten bereichen hat sich hier
ausgezahlt
das ist eine region kamen viele legt die
mir das weiter gegeben diese erfahrung
von feuern zum 33 und dann habe ich
einfach die position gab bezahlen muss
einzumischen graf aber nicht jeden tag
und das aber schwer ertrag war immer
dann hat ja auch gesagt wir liebst mich
nicht ernst und der schatz ich aber dann
am ende der zeit aufgeklärt und wie viel
besser gegangen
aber was immer auch war erwirbt den ganz
großen gestaltetes nachkriegspolitik war
ja dann 1980 kanzlerkandidat
haben sie eigentlich geahnt dass er so
schlecht abschneiden würde also zunächst
einmal war ich entschieden dagegen
erkannte kandidat wird aber nie ein hehl
daraus gemacht
es war für mich gar nach der
vorgeschichte dass sich 80 wenn ich
antrete wiederum in dieser
auseinandersetzung kamen dann habe ich
muss jetzt alles anderes vorgeschlagen
gehabt
in der die in der cdu war dabei durch
spaltung in bestimmten bereichen und als
er dann nominiert war die parole
ausgegeben
egal was eine ding es wird alles getan
in diesem wahlkampf um ihn zu
unterstützen und ich habe mehr war
zusammen mit jeder an brücken in diesem
wahlkampf was wir dann sehr gut getan
hat auch in der partei aber ich habe
mich wieder einmal gerechnet er selbst
war übrigens dann doch sehr beeindruckt
davon wie ich mich für ihn eingesetzt
habe 1980 zwischen das wieder man
vergessen dann in der zeit danach aber
es essen servustv ruhiger geworden aber
es ändert nichts an der tatsache dass
wir uns um zeit zu zeit ich als jemand
gewaltig gekracht haben wenn sie die
struktur der deutschen wählerschaft
gehen können sie sich vorstellen dass
überhaupt jemals ein csu-vorsitzender
gewinnen könnte natürlich ich glaube das
ist das was beispielsweise nicht primär
nur dabei sondern der französische
strauß und er hatte ja die kokettiert
damit wir uns ja nicht vergessen
also hätte als koppelung ein anderes
beispiel sagen
während bei aber kein mensch bleiben er
war nie angst als kontrakt auch war aber
wenn der autor scott war kommt
abgetreten ist nordrhein westfalen das
und zu oder wenn sie hans er ab ganz
früh nehmen
oder wenn sie die die anderen großen
gestalten dass sie nun diesen jahren
nehmen die wahren bayern aber am zweiten
beispiel franken natürlich in einem ganz
bestimmten auftreten auch da war dass
sich davon so sympathisch schon sehr
kultiviert und banal in der
bundestagsfraktion und auf dem parteitag
der cdu losgelegt hat eine mischung von
anerkennung und zu schießen dann hat es
schon das so geprägt es muss einer der
aus bayern kommende zu machen das kann
man auch genauso wie werde ich glaube
nicht mehr dass das dokument
sie sind dann kanzler geworden nicht
durch eine wahl sondern wie es bisher
bei uns ja in deutschland üblich war
durch einen koalitionswechsel der fand
im september 82 statt
nun gibt es daher vorher immer
vorbereitende gespräche hatten sie den
sommer über mit genfer schon allein
durch seine farmer ich habe das ende der
koalition vorausgesagt
da fühlen uns nicht keine große kunst
dazu es war ganz eindeutig dass die
sozialdemokraten dann für wichtige teile
der sozialdemokraten in boots mit
verlassen hatten
das galt in der ganz zentralen frage der
stationierung also das mit der
mittelstrecken und dass das
nachrüstungsbeschluss galt für teile der
finanz und wirtschafts und sozialpolitik
und es war deutlich zu sehen er auch die
stahl die laufenden verluste an
landtagswahlen
dass er dies nur noch eine bestimmte
zeit macht und ich habe zu einem
zeitpunkt aber der war mindestens zehn
monate vor dem ersten oktober dem ich so
zum bundeskanzler gewählt wurde 1902
nacht am ende gesagt ihr müsst wissen du
musst wissen jetzt und nicht ohne netz
aber was der über zelte dass wir uns im
sommer das hat ja davon führte stars
immer behauptet aber etwas ganz anderes
er wollte ja müsste letzte
legislaturperiode über der gegner die
fdp 105 prozent zu drücken
die wartung dass da alle möglichen
gesprächen des falls ich habe in diesem
sommer überhaupt keinen kontakt
fleischmann telefoniert mit hans
dietrich genscher gab und das war mein
gesprächspartner oder war platz davor
damals in einer an ein höhenflug wo er
mich eher von oben betrachten
sie wurden dann bundeskanzler und haben
wir ganz schnell gesamten müssen neue
parteien haben das war nicht
unumstritten
aber warum sind sie trotzdem drauf
geblieben weil ich hab keine mehrheit
hatte
ich hatte natürlich eine rechnerische
mehrheit aber es war doch die zentrale
frage aller fragen die erlösende
ausgangspunkt für die kommende zeit war
ohne diese entscheidung ist eine deutsch
einheit gegeben werden wir den nato
doppelbeschluss realisieren oder nicht
und sie spielen man an einem samstag ihr
vor dem haus gestartet da waren rund
400.000 leute hier frei fliegt ab gehen
wenn dieser zu rücken zur wand standen
und haben gegen die nachrüstung
nachrüstungsbeschluss demonstriert und
ich war der meinung ich bleibe weiterhin
der auffassung dass war abseits sich
richtige wir können diesen bestimmten
modus setze mich wollt in dieser war
zwingend notwendig dabei alle diese
leute seien haben sie da nicht
vergleichen zweifel bis jetzt werde auf
den punkt noch gerade sonst gerne darauf
zurück und da war ja eine geliehene
mehrheit nicht dass ausreichende wir
waren unter anderen gesichtspunkten ja
voran der wahl gewesen die 80er war fand
ja nicht unter diesen bis ich eine rom
contra strauß wahl gewesen
eine personalentscheidung straßen
schmidt du nicht die gleiche frage
und das war ziemlich schwierig auch er
vom juristischen der damalige der
damalige chef des kanzleramtes war
thomas reichenberger hat eine große
leistung erbracht
und es war auch der vorteil dass mit ihm
und dem bundespräsidenten karaffen zwei
ganz hochkarätig jurist afx rechts
juristen am werk war
so ist dann diese lösung gefunden worden
über die man da gibt's kein zweifel
unterschiedlicher meinung sein können
das war auch damals so das ist die
juristen trotzdem war es richtig
die leserfrage ich habe keinen zweifel
dass das absolut richtig war
ich wusste natürlich vieles von dem man
sich heute war es nicht aber es war eher
ein augenblick in dem das geschah in dem
durch den wechsel im präsidentenamt in
der verein bei den vereinigten staaten
und ringo präsident geworden
ein präsident in der arena getreten war
der ganz klar sagte ein krieg kann
hoffentlich keine denkbare möglichkeit
er kriegt muss vermieden werden aber die
müssen das in moskau begreifen und das
war ja der ausgehen dass zeitabschnitt
der agonie der breschnew ära mit all dem
ausland kam und die moskauer die leute
in moskau das ist mir ich selbst daraus
im gespräch mit körperschaft haben ja
dann wider besseres wissen zum teil
diese hoch ist uns debatte aufgenommen
mit dem ergebnis dass sie auf der
strecke geblieben sind aber sie haben
immerhin während wir hier diskutierten
demonstrierten 5,3 millionen waffen der
männer und frauen unter waffen gehabt
die größte armee die optik ba war mit
einer veränderung der militär vor die
jedes mit ihrem panzer roten damals sind
die militärs sind raum hat in 16 tagen
quer durch deutschland in frankreich an
den kanal zu kommen
unter gab es eben nur zwei möglichkeiten
siehst du unterwerfen oder zu stehen und
die politik des 47 ausgeführt werden
gerade geschildert wie sie hier starten
vom kanzleramt aus und sehen diese
hunderttausenden von demonstranten
sie sind jemand dem man über nachgesagt
wird das ehrgefühl haben für stimmungen
für das volk für das denken warum sie da
nicht mal gezweifelt gesagt haben
vielleicht haben die recht die frage
habe ich mir natürlich bestimmt werden
sie wenn sie da an einem motorrad sitzen
die passung von
das ist ja ein idealer gegner zum
nachdenken als hier nicht dem boden
entwachsen sind wir haben ja noch ein
polit aktiv in der früher selbst sichern
die frage und sieht das nichtvergessen
zwar nicht so ruhig bienenstand sind die
leute doch gekommenen zwei schritte
jetzt nicht von provokateuren oder so in
diesem haus hier hatte ich damals eine
bank gegeben
für die krebshilfe von nietzsche und
hoch respektable zeit genossen dabei an
das sehe ich noch viel auf mich zukommt
sie machen kriegen dieser politik das
habe ich nicht einfach abgeschüttelt
das ist eine sache gewesen die schon
unter die haut liegt nun ich für absolut
überzeugt das habe ich mir einen zweifel
gehabt wenn wir jetzt dem imperialismus
in moskau nachgeben
finger weg vom fenster das war nun eine
geschichtliche erfahrung die die
deutschen und die welt gemacht hat 1938
es ist eigentlich schwierig wenn man aus
der opposition kommt dann die angst
geschäfte so zu übernehmen so schwierig
aber jeder muss seine eigene handschrift
haben wir sind sie ich bin ja nun
geländer ministerpräsident gewesen
habt was allerdings diese art etiketten
beobachtungen er erlebt als ich als bonn
kam war ich der erfolgreichste minister
briten verstand viel von in politiken
der augenblick als ich das selber die
vögel der nation dargestellt was ich
dann später wiederum gedreht sind sie
wie blöd dass alles zum großen teil ist
solche etikettierung aber es ist schon
allein das dürfen sie nicht vergessen
ein problem der leute die cdu es 1969 in
opposition gekommen und 82 in die
regierung zurückgekehrt das ist
politisch gesehen eine generation
sie ist ja nicht mehr die zahl der jahre
sondern der weg
im parlament bei beamten vieles andere
und in der opposition das sagte
politologe dass man sich in der
opposition regeneriert in der opposition
ist die disziplin und das hat gar keinen
vorwurf machen
das sitzen kollegen die klassenfahrt ein
ganz weg sitzt im ausschuss habe eine
prima idee aber damit die hand gehoben
haben sie weniger in der abstimmung und
jetzt ist nicht das ist nicht motivieren
sondern ist demotivierend einer weile
kommt dann plötzlich die stimmung beim
gott warum soll man das machen und das
hat uns natürlich auch erreicht vor
allem weiß ja ein umdenken gab 1909
gewichtigen der form dass eine menge bei
uns sagten könnte der namen nennen
die sagten wir brauchen die koffer gar
nicht auszupacken ein paar wochen sind
die weg ich habe nur dann zwei nacht ist
genau das umgekehrte er liebt ja bekannt
der bundesminister seinen kollegen
damals spd wandel sagte der bleibt nicht
nur vier jahre von dampfenden ausgelacht
in katar kapsel menge leute die sagten
ja gut in 68 wochen
ein bekanntes deutsches druck erzeugt
ist aus hamburger damals in der
redaktionskonferenz der damalige
chefredakteur
das ist nicht das was sie jetzt
automatisch an endes lieber andere
bürger bedeuten und die these vertreten
wir müssen schlechte journalisten zahlen
wenn man sie nicht ein viertel
jahrhundert geschrieben das soll
zeitangaben sind immer glücklich und
wenn man hat anfängt muss man sich
völlig ändern auch die kanzlei ob es ein
harter job
sie können sich im land das eine oder
andere erlauben in bonn kann sich nicht
erlauben sie müssen fit sein zu wissen
präsent sein und waren sehr mir gar kein
erbarmen zwanziger hat der auswärtige
politik darf nicht vergessen
ich habe nie meister die gute beziehung
zum franzosen gab und so aber das war's
für belastet war ein treffen wie die
show oder so aber das war's dann rein
strikt und was ganz andere integration
also vernichtet wir haben dann von der
geistig moralischen wende gesprochen
das ist dann auch der diskutiert worden
falls du dir worten zitiert worden wie
was gemeint ja wie gesagt haben das sage
ich ihnen wieder
es wird alle auch die politik hat einen
beitrag so gab sich nur als wenn das
klappt nie gesagt dass ich die sache der
politik auch die sache der politik aber
wenn sie wenn sie beispielsweise jetzt
ein aktuelles thema aufnehmen
den standort in der verfassung von ehe
und familie
[Musik]
die schuld dafür dass das erste wort in
diesem fall nicht von der politik
sondern von den kirchen kommt
beispielsweise dass die politik sich
auch dazu bekennen
ich hoffte dass wir in sehr kurzer zeit
aus den diskussionen der nachbarschaft
in den niederlanden eine diskussion
bekommen vor diesem viertel nämlich zu
dem stichwort alternativ siegerin nicht
das gleiche bedeutet wie für uns wir
über ganz bestimmte erinnerungen da ich
da muss die politik im ort machen aber
es könnten möglich so sein dass jetzt
sieht der rechter gesellschaft dass auch
die politik delegiert das erwarte ich
dass die wissenschaft der medizin am
navi philosophie theologie ihren
belastet sie sind anfang oktober zum
kanzler ernannt worden und am selben tag
nur wenige später mit dem flugzeug stieg
nach paris geflogen ich bin freitags zum
kanzler gewählt worden
ich bin am samstag mit ein paar
mitarbeiter in meiner familie umgezogen
lassen und gar keiner gewertet werden
samstagmittag auf vorbilder um 11 uhr
können sie nahezu alles im regierungsrat
und machen
von kindern aber die regierungs
eingeschworen worden um 13 uhr am montag
und 17 uhr bin ich mir ansehen die
treppe herauf warum man für mich und das
hat sich nicht geändert immer klar war
dass wir europa gemeinsam mit nachbarn
bilden können bauen können aber dass das
verhältnis zwischen deutschland und
frankreich am ball fällt ist eigenartig
es gibt auch ein feld mit eigener
abfließen deutschland den polen damit es
so ziemlich gut versteckt zwischen
deutschland und israel
nur es ist ein andere fragestellung und
was war der ausgangsposition war sogar
mit daran denn ich hatte überhaupt nicht
kannte ich auch keine beziehung ist gab
auch nicht beiden seiten auf die spur
einer besonderen sympathie er war die
länder aber sonst erlebt
ich war christdemokrat und ich bin da
die gefahren um von vornherein zu
signalisieren ich will mit ihm beim im
vergleich das menschenmögliche
wahlscheinen stück an prüfung an der
agnes überlegungen und von adler habe
ich einsatz gelernt denn viele ablehnen
aber der trotzdem gescheit ist da immer
gesagt man muss die trikolore drei mann
begrüßen die bundesflagge einmal viele
die den patienten die ihn so habt ihr
weniger respekt vor der eigenen flagge
dass er damit überhaupt nichts zu tun
aber frank geschichte kaunas und siegt
natürlich sagen wieso sind die
dekoration kamera alles vertreten
aber die franzosen etwas machen fordert
geschichtliches immer in der perspektive
etwas anders gelaufen
die band die franzosen haben den
amerikanern oberst unabhängigkeitskrieg
geholfen
der name lafayette ist in jedem
schulbuch zu finden
und wenn ihre einkommen nach new york
steht
die freiheit starb der mann der zwar
schicken die organisatoren profitieren
am stärken an den erinnert gerade noch
die steuben parade mit dem amerikaner
sagen wieso wo wir sie einmal die
entscheidungsschlacht betrachten
ja für ein beispiel die die
unabhängigkeit entschieden hat da waren
auf der britischen großartigen die
washington seite standen hessische
regimenter die der landgraf versteuert
hatten auf der couch auf der
französischen plan des standes regiment
zweibrücken dpa alte brown hat sich das
x dem anerkannten präsidenten versucht
zu erleiden war ganz sprachlos dass es
auch deutsche waren auf beiden seiten
der palisaden aber das ist eine
geschichte eben nachgegangen so kann ich
die liste beliebig fortsetzen
und es war für mich ganz wichtig dass
wir kontakt bekommen dann ist das
eingetreten womit man nicht rechnen
konnte bei so unterschiedlichen leuten
das wegen der unterschiedlichkeit da
seine herzliche freundschaft erwachsen
ist gerade weil wir so total
unterschiedlich warm
der bundeskanzler